nos piden mover el punto a 7 sextos en
la recta numérica
así que pausa este vídeo puedo mover
este punto por aquí pero te invito a
pausar el vídeo y poner tu dedo en donde
estaría 7 sextos en la recta numérica
muy bien trabajemos juntos en esto lo
que dicen es de 0 a este punto en la
recta numérica justo aquí nos lleva a un
sexto de modo que cada uno de estos
espacios es un sexto así que vamos a
hacer un sexto dos sextos tres sextos
cuatro sextos cinco sextos seis sextos
siete sextos déjame asegurarme que tengo
siete sextos cada uno de estos espacios
son un sexto entonces tenemos uno dos
tres cuatro cinco seis siete sextos esto
es siete sextos en la recta numérica
ahora tenemos otras formas de llegar a
la misma idea por ejemplo dicen cuál
punto está en nueve cuartos en la recta
numérica y nos piden que elijamos una
respuesta podemos ver las opciones aquí
así
qué opción muestra nueve cuartos en la
recta numérica pausa el vídeo y trata de
elegir la respuesta muy bien veamos cada
opción parece que en la primera opción
el espacio entre 0 y 1 se divide en uno
dos tres cuatro espacios iguales
entonces a medida que avanzamos de 0 a
la siguiente línea tenemos un cuarto y
eso parece que continúa entonces esto es
un cuarto dos cuartos tres cuartos
cuatro cuartos 5 464 siete cuartos ocho
cuartos y nueve cuartos está aquí esto
es lo que estamos buscando pero el punto
no está en nueve cuartos está en diez
cuartos once cuartos está en doce
cuartos no me gusta la opción veamos la
opción b hemos dividido el espacio entre
cero y uno en uno dos tres cuatro cinco
o seis espacios iguales de modo que cada
uno de estos espacios es un sexto para
pasar de cero a uno ya hemos pasado seis
sextos y luego siete sextos ocho sextos
sextos esto es 9 sextos no nueve cuartos
veamos esta última opción ya siento que
debería ser la respuesta pero podemos
ver que los espacios son iguales que
nuestra primera opción entonces estos
son cuartos lo sé porque el espacio
entre 0 y 1 o el espacio entre dos
números enteros se divide en cuatro
espacios iguales así que para ir de 0 a
1 avanzamos a 4 cuartos y luego 5 4 647
cuartos ocho cuartos y nueve cuartos
definitivamente la opción se se ve bien
hagamos un ejemplo más
aquí nos preguntan qué fracción se ubica
en el punto en la recta numérica pausa
este vídeo y trata de responder muy bien
entre los números enteros cuántos
espacios iguales tenemos parece que
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 espacios iguales los
enteros se dividen en sextos entonces un
sexto dos sextos tres sextos cuatro
sextos cinco sextos seis sextos que es
igual a un entero
7 sextos así que esto es 7 sobre 6 justo
así y hemos terminado